president donald trump visited fort
mchenry in baltimore
the site of a victory by u.s forces over
british invaders in
1814. the president framed the struggle
to control the coronavirus pandemic in
military terms
together we will vanquish the virus
and america will rise from this crisis
to new
and even greater heights as our brave
warriors have shown us from
the nation's earliest days in america we
are the captains
of our own fate in less than six months
covet 19 has killed more americans
than all who died in the vietnam war
the war in korea and the conflicts in
iraq and afghanistan
combined former vice president joe biden
the presumptive democratic party nominee
made his first public appearance in two
months
he and his wife jill laid a wreath at a
veterans memorial in delaware
the bidens wore masks something trump
has refused to do in public
the world health organization announced
it was stopping trials of the
anti-malarial drug
hydroxychloroquine due to safety
concerns
trump has touted the drug as a treatment
for covet 19
and claimed he has been taking it to
ward off infection
despite lack of scientific evidence of
its effectiveness
the who's head of emergency programs
warned countries to remain
vigilant to avoid a resurgence of the
pandemic
countries around the world have to
continue to
put in place the the the public health
and social measures
the surveillance measures the public
health measures the testing measures
and a comprehensive strategy to ensure
that we continue
on a downward trajectory and that we
don't
have an immediate second peak but social
distancing seemed
far from the minds of parents and
children who flocked to a water park in
texas
the park reopened despite orders by the
state's governor
that amusement parks should remain
closed
some splashy holiday fun heedless
of potentially serious risks rob
reynolds al jazeera